[Applause]
[Music]
the situation had been tense for years
but on June the 5th 2017 suddenly the
conflict reached another dimension Saudi
Arabia the Arab Emirates Bahrain in
Egypt announced the fulminating rupture
of their relations with the emirate of
Qatar including the closing of borders
and the prohibition of the use of ports
and airspace suddenly all communication
was cut off it was practically a total
blockade the next night planes and cargo
ships bound for Qatar were forced to
change course not even the camels were
spared the Saudis immediately expelled
no less than 12,000 camels that were
grazing in their country yep you heard
that right so with their only land
border closed up in practical terms the
emirate of Qatar went from being a
peninsula to becoming an island
threatened by its neighbors by land sea
and air at the time this was happening
these questions were asked how long can
guitar hold on for are we facing the
prelude to a military intervention and
has this emirate splendor reached its
end well today in this video we're gonna
see exactly what happens how things are
today and what we can expect in the
future
[Music]
the results now we are going to see the
results but first what you might be
wondering how did they get into this
situation in the first place what the
hell happened as in almost all disputes
there are lots of reasons on the table
but the truth is that the Riyadh and Abu
Dhabi government swept tires of Qatar
always being free and above all they
wanted to cut off their growing
relations with Iran and close down al
Jazeera once and for all in fact these
were the basic conditions that were
imposed on guitar in order to start a
dialogue after agreeing on the blockade
conditions that Doha outright rejected
but having said all of that let's get
right to the point at first everyone bet
that this whole mess would be temporary
and that it would resolve relatively
quickly one way or another after all who
would think that such a small country
the country that has barely 2 million
inhabitants and that is practically a
desert would be able to resist for very
long without simply giving up it seems
pretty impossible right well do view it
that's precisely what is happening it
has not resulted in the way they wanted
it to they wanted to take control of our
decisions and get us to comply with
their demands that has failed Qatar will
never be for sale to the blockaded
countries or to anyone else we are a
sovereign country we will remain a
sovereign country
Saif Al Thani Director of Qatar's
government communications office as you
can imagine throughout the first few
hours the emirate underwent a very very
tense situation many supplies including
basic products such as food stopped
arriving the Doha stock market collapsed
and even the option of military
intervention didn't seem far-fetched
after all the small Qatari army was no
match for the billion dollar war
machines of its neighboring countries
now a successful intervention that
depended on the approval of the United
States which has one of its most
important military bases in the world
located in Qatar as even though this
approval was likely just in case
Doha decided to ask fist angles help
[Music]
Turkish Parliament approves bill to
deploy troops in Qatar the situation
well it was looking to be quite
difficult and quite complex but hold on
a moment because Qatar well had another
ace up their sleeve as we told you in a
previous video in recent years the
Emirates they've done their homework
thanks to its oil and especially natural
gas exploitation the country has managed
to accumulate a fortune of more than
three hundred billion dollars a fortune
by the way that they've invested all
over the planet
[Music]
and not only that but it also managed to
become a country that's much more open
to the world a country with a foreign
policy that's independent of its
neighbors and that's precisely what made
this blockade a total failure
if the blockade strategy was to corner
us economically that has completely
failed and it will not work
Ali Sharif al-ahmadi finance minister of
Qatar musi in recent months the stock
market has recovered investors
they've stopped running away and even
though many prices rose due to the
blockade even the International Monetary
Fund in a report it published on March
the 5th 2018 stated that the Qatari
economy would grow by almost 3 percent
this year the fact is that the country
hasn't only managed to open new
commercial routes and achieve
alternatives to transport its
merchandise many multinationals located
in Dubai who can no longer send their
people by plane to Doha have decided to
open their own officers there this means
that for example the number of companies
in the financial center has grown by 70%
in the last year
for the past 15 years we were the
fastest-growing economy on the planet
you are talking about a six billion
dollar economy in 2000 into a two
hundred billion dollar economy in 2015
the blockading countries tried to make
businesses decide between them and Qatar
that they backed away
Yusuf Mohammed Al Quaeda the head of the
Qatar financial Authority tivua it might
actually seem that this blockade might
actually end up helping Qatar and if you
don't believe me
well perhaps listen to this
[Music]
changes in Qatar the blockade it is
clearly being a challenge for the Qatari
economy and their society having an
isolated country like that it's
generally a really terrible deal now
precisely due to that during this time
one of the emirate government's biggest
priorities has been to compensate for
the blockades negative consequences and
convince investors that Qatar is still a
good country to invest in that and to
try and gain a lot of influence around
the world this is something that's
indispensible to prevent its inators
especially Saudi Arabia from getting
future expansionist temptations but now
you may be wondering well how can they
achieve all of this
[Music]
well one way is by pushing reforms and
that's something they've done in recent
months the Qatari government has
promoted several changes to improve the
country's image in the world's can to be
more competitive for international
investors for example visas have been
removed for more than 80 countries the
rights of foreign residents have
increased and more free zones have been
established further two very important
changes have been announced for one they
called for elections for the very first
time to elect members for the consultive
assembly something like a local
parliament now this is pretty limited
Parliament's but at least it's a step in
the right direction and this is a
particularly important step when we
account for the fact that we're talking
about a place that still works with a
political system based on absolute
monarchy and for another the more than
reprehensible fela system will be coming
to an end
this is a system that makes foreign
workers especially the poorest have to
rely on their employers for their visa
and legal status and has very few legal
repercussions for exploitation making
working conditions very very bad in some
cases you've probably heard of the
allegations about slave workers in the
Persian Gulf well this is what we're
talking about however now with the
latest labor changes all of these
workers will have better protected
rights and will be able to change jobs
or leave the country whenever they want
all of these reforms would have taken a
lot longer were it not for the blockade
it's been a blessing in disguise when it
comes to business you see Muhammed
al-qaeda head of the Qatar financial
Authority in other words the blockade is
achieving things that the international
community has been demanding for years
but having said that we still have a
very very important question to answer
do you know what Qatar strategy has been
to gain influence in the world and
strengthen its position well listen up
the strategy
I think we all know that there are very
influential economic sectors in the
world well two industries in particular
stand out one due to its ability to
influence politics and another due to
its ability to influence society
yes dear viewer I'm talking about the
military industry and the entertainment
industry and you know what it's
precisely in these industries that Qatar
has concentrated its strategy
[Music]
[Applause]
in recent months the Qatari government
has announced military contracts for
more than 25 billion dollars and yes one
of their objectives is to equip their
army to if necessary make invasions more
difficult but the truth is that no
matter how much they invest in weapons
Qatar won't be able to replicate Saudi
Arabia's military power but wait just a
moment because there's another objective
what better way to influence Washington
and get support than by making an
industry that practically every
government in the world consider
strategic happy in this case most of the
contracts went to the United States and
to European countries that didn't
support the blockade is where the United
Kingdom France and Germany planes tanks
helicopters missiles Qatar is buying
everything of course it's never going to
be able to reach Saudi Arabia's level
but it has suddenly become a very
prominent client yes the truth is that
Qataris are really experts in
contracting security policies
and that's not all by the way Joe Harris
also announced that it wants to invest
more money in our indeed the base of the
United States military has in the
country this is a base with more than
10,000 soldiers and 100 deployed
aircrafts including b-52 bombers as we
mentioned it is one of the most
important United States bases in the
world
yes it's really from Qatar where the
United States projects its strength in
the area and this includes for its
incursions into Iraq Afghanistan Syria
etc etc etc by the way the base cost a
billion dollars and was a gift from the
Qatari government who also contributes
to their expenses every year so yes
suffice to say it was just in case
Qatar signs an agreement with Turkey to
establish a naval base in its territory
now in the other industry the
entertainment industry Qatar has been
moving like a fish in water for years
especially as far as sports are
concerned
[Music]
in 2022 the country will host the World
Cup in 2012 it bought PSG france's most
important football team and doha the
country's capital has been an Olympic
contender several times and not only
that they also created Bynes sports an
Al Jazeera subsidiary that has become
one of the largest sport competition
broadcasting rights owners in the world
well after announcing the blockage the
Qatari authorities decided to reinforce
this strategy which for example leds the
PSG to spend billions and billions of
dollars on signings along with joining
PSG on a 5-year contract and 354 million
dollars Neymar also committed to act as
spokesman for the Qatar World Cup in
this way not only did PSG acquire the
player who would elevate the team's
presence on the European stage but Qatar
obtained a symbol of its defiance in the
face of its attempted isolation abdullah
al r an assistant professor of history
at Georgetown University School of
Foreign Service in Qatar well with the
military industry with football and by
pouring millions of dollars into
Washington lobbies the Qatari government
hopes to reinforce its position and
improve its image now of course their
rivals are also beginning to make moves
so the battle is not over yet
but that's something we can talk about
another day for now it's your turn
what country do you think will be
reinforced by this blockade well leave
us your answer in the comments below and
in this survey we really do like knowing
about your opinion and I really hope you
did enjoy this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday also don't forget to check out
our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]